my lips honestly feel like like this
looking right now
so today we're wearing long-lasting lip
wear to see how long they actually last
we've seen a ton of commercials on how
lipstick is supposed to last forever
because that's what we want we're going
to put four different lipsticks to the
test through a series of Olympic events
event number one have a damn good cup of
coffee event number two eat a goddamn
taco event number three kiss a hottie
and lips we've each been randomly
assigned one of the lipsticks and we
won't know until the end of the day
which one we're actually wearing
we can't reapply or see our lips until
the end of the day it's ladylike and
we're about to plate let's take a little
bit shut up
I'm trying okay that feels very dry but
it feels very serious like it's gonna
stay when she was putting it on it kind
of smelled like nail polish it's not
feeling too bad yet I'm pretty sure
throughout the end of the day it's gonna
get a little dry I'm excited smells like
a starburst so I think it's a sign of
good times to come don't eat all of
these things I'm drinking tea because I
don't drink coffee
did it go up what did it come off it
didn't go oh my god like Chantal is like
already in first place what the hell
I'll have what she's having
it's definitely dripping on your phone
right yeah
little bits came off yeah no this is
like kind of girls by default I'm in
second place static I don't feel like my
song gonna come off it's so dry we're
saying it's still dry it is dry oh wait
wait
crumbly to discuss all their their
crumbly come in hot I have low hopes
with oh she is a line whoa
I am clearly in last place right now who
has more crumbles me or that I have on
top so I think mine's worse maybe I just
like made out with it all differently
you know maybe I was like sorry what all
right I've been number one concluded I
like to win so I'm happy that I'm in
first place
- next event eat a damn taco nothing I
got nothing I actually don't think I
have anything either
I got felicity Jan I have a someone with
corners specs again it's also on my
hands my god what am I an animal the
more bites I take I'm going to see
crumbles oh how the mighty have hole my
lips are gonna be dry for making out
with this guy and like I got to be soft
and supple I feel like I'm really
nothing left on my lips for Tyler to
even get off but like I'm excited for
him to have to make out with me after
Taco Bell I'm like losing this is dumb I
I quit event number three case a boy I
know him and we're gonna kiss I guess I
feel kind of nauseous those are breath
mint you're welcome hey nice to meet you
listen alright you wanna treat it no no
second is it in my beard no just on your
lips but you can't really see it it's
one step there's nothing on his face
this is amazing I think there's someone
is saliva it's like in between his teeth
I'm so sorry what's not on your face you
won't try again maybe yo oh can you see
this a little bit specks yeah look at
that
fantastic hope I look good I mean damn
oh okay so I was right you can clearly
see that my lips are dying of lack of
water I can see like the creases of my
lips like very definitively it's like
color skin color like a skin - Oreo on
my lip I don't know that's just like
nother thing slips of some crap whatever
I had a good kisser so I'll blame it on
that
I hope my looks weren't looking like
this and I kissed that boy earlier
that's probably why he wouldn't make out
with me we did do some olympic tests to
this stuff had it held up okay it just
didn't it didn't do its job I am the
winner
oh it's like I'm not beat up about it
lady tip lady parts long wear lipstick
Olympic tested done you know at first I
thought it was a tortoise and a hare
situation where I'm the tortoise and
I'll make it and people were just
overconfident but I just ended up being
a tortoise in reality in that story
where I just keep going slow and I never
made it it's here is he
what get it
there I never got it get it yeah you get
it it's here quick